m de la rigolade de la bonne humeur à la
pâte auch et bien sûr tout ce qu'il a
demandé de mettre avec quoi c'est pas
cool l'alcool c'est pas le cool oui
c'est pas cool ce que tu dis là patrice
remettez votre bermuda c'est un
programme familial si je plaisante quoi
c'est pas con le faire de belles photos
nettes à l'ats patrice pourquoi yann
hamon cool d'alcool j'ai jamais dit non
pas six sauf une fois parce qu'il était
déjà servi un plan à trois
un rapport sexuel mal à m'en aller je
sens les caoutchoucs ouais on football
aux tamponnais ballon au volley ball on
envoie les ballons et c'est pas ta
chaussettes tous les ballons j'en ai
ballast
patrice 69 année érotique non 51 le
pastis non sommes 2 et de pastis dans
cohabitation il ya le mot bits à ça je
plaisante